how to properly test your script the
absolute importance of script testing
what is what is script testing script
script testing so when I was starting
out a manager did this for me and I'll
forever be grateful so the way it works
is most people they'll write a script
and I'll give the friends their writing
group people they trust and they want
feedback you know what's working what's
not working fatigue suggestions way to
improve it and what I was taught and I
see a lot of the more success writers
working that way working this way is
they don't start their what they start
with is script testing and what script
testing is is the first thing is you
realize that when you write a script you
experience a movie you experience
characters and when someone reads your
script a movie plays in their head and
they experience a story and they
experience characters now a lot of
people make the assumption that the
movie that plays in my head is really
similar the movie it plays in your head
script testing is strategically asking a
series of questions to find out what
movie is playing in someone else's head
what story are they watching what's
happening why is it happening why is it
interesting or not interesting who are
the characters what a how are they
experiencing the characters how would
they describe the characters are they
engaged with the characters or they not
engage with the characters and it's
literally be able to track what they're
experiencing story and character wise as
they move through your script and what
script testing aims for is not to know
if someone likes your script loves it
hates it
suggestions critique not at first the
first is are they experiencing what I'm
experiencing and if they're not why not
what are they experiencing different
from me so when I first started teaching
at UCLA I did a I had everyone bring in
seven copies of their script and so
let's say you and I would switch scripts
I'd give you seven copies of my script
you'd give me seven copies of your
script you would take my seven copies
and go to seven of your friends and say
hey will you read a script by someone in
my class hi
read it and you don't have to have
anything smart to say you don't think it
feedback you just have to answer
questions about what you experienced
when you read the script and you really
make it clear that you're not testing
their reading comprehension it's testing
the writers ability to have it come off
the page and so let's say seven of your
friends say okay I'll do that so they
read my script and then I would armed
you with a series of questions that you
would ask those writers and you would
record the the conversation and it's
really important that you haven't read
the script because you'll ask the
question about the story or the
character and one of your friends would
start to give an answer and then say is
that right and you would say I don't
know I didn't read the script and so at
some point they'll just relax and
they'll just tell you what they
experienced and you record that all
seven of your friends and then you come
back to class and give me the recordings
and I would do the same for you and then
I would have each writer transcribe the
recordings because you really have to
hear it if you transcribe it I have to
admit when I first started teaching at
UCLA there were things I did not were
successful there were things that there
was a lot of trial and error when I
first started teaching this was a real
mixed bag because people were so
demoralized to have a script they poured
heart and soul into characters they
loved more than anything and this is
their character but everyone else was
seeing this and this is like no this is
despicable and this was an amazing
character and a lot of people will come
up to me and they're like you know be
careful of Julie in the class because I
think there's something wrong with Julie
because Julie's friends are like all
schizophrenic I'm telling you because
look at the feedback her friends are so
there was that there was one person who
just dropped out of an MFA program she
did come back oh and then I had another
woman threatened to kill herself
oh she didn't but that's when I stopped
doing this exercise mandatory and I
would make it you know voluntary yeah
she did not kill her okay a lot of
people came out of that class went on to
be working writers and they said that
this experience was the most painful
experience they had as a writer but the
most valuable because they didn't
why's that not everything that they were
putting on the page was fully coming off
the page to other people and there are
so many people that write scripts to get
rejected in the marketplace or they
don't get an agent to represent them or
a manager and they feel like locating my
characters or story something's not
strong enough that might be true and it
might not be true it might be that if
people actually fully experience your
characters and your story they would
have fallen in love with it but they
didn't here's a true story now this is
not a rep this is not an average
representation because this is a little
clean and easy it's not usually this
clean and easy but it'll it'll
illustrate a point so an agent sent me a
writer I not quite a year ago close to a
year ago and is a really talented writer
who's staffed on some really prestigious
shows but had never been able to sell
original content always her stuff was
great but it just wasn't great enough so
the the manager had soft had soft shown
as shown the script to some people in
the industry that he trusted to sort of
unofficially get feedback on it and
people love there's two main characters
they love this character they loved the
concept they loved the engine they loved
were this guy but the second main
character found annoying just honestly
like if this character wasn't in the
story I would really be interested in
this but this character just ruined it
for me and that was hard for the writer
to hear because this character was the
main character as far as she was
concerned and it was sort of reflection
it was sort of an autobiographical II
emotionally based character to her so
that always hurts because then they're
not just rejecting your writing it feels
like they're rejecting you so what I do
when I work with a rioter is a set of
reading their script and giving them my
opinions I always start with what I
won't know the movie that plays in their
head I want to know how they experience
the story and the characters to see
where it's not coming off the page the
way they see it and I knew because she
shared with me that this character was
the main issue so I started with
character and I just asked her a series
of questions describe the character to
me and then whenever she said I'd say
well why is the character this way and
why does why is the character this way
and what is the character love more than
anything in the world and why is that
and what do they fear more than anything
the world and why is that
and when this happened in the script why
did the character do it and why do you
find that so compelling and when the
character did this why did it and so it
was it was a good 30 to 40 minutes and
when we were done I could I could
identify two pieces of essential context
and let me just stop and define how I
would define essential context I would
define essential context as everything
the audience reader or viewer everything
the audience needs to know or experience
to understand what's happening why it's
happening and why they should care and
that's true for the story and for the
character and I was able to identify two
pieces of essential context that were
not in the script there was something
about the characters motivation for the
main thing they were trying to achieve
that it wasn't clear to a reader and
there was also something about the
characters backstory that I think was
really important
the writer kept talking about this as
part of why she cared so much about the
character and it wasn't clearing the
script and at first the writer is like
well of course it's clear and then I
would ask them to highlight where it's
clear and then in doing that the writer
was able to realize oh it's it's implied
but I could see how amount now someone
may not get that and then the other
piece of essential context was gone I
mean it I'm sorry in an original draft
that was there but as she rewrote it and
rewrote it it somehow got removed this
is a really common experience and just
wasn't there
and she didn't catch that because when
she reads her script the movie that and
the characters that play in her head she
knows all of this she loves these
characters she knows exactly this
character is her so of course she knows
exactly why the character is doing it
now again this punch line is is really
clean and simple it's not usually this
clean and simple but with this
particular writer and again
three or four
very senior people in the industry at
production companies had read the script
and said really like this really love
this but this character ruins it for me
okay
we just went it well she just went in
and she changed one line of dialogue to
make something crystal clear and then
she added a scene it was about a two
page scene to get that essential context
across in the script so one change one
line of dialogue and added a new scene
that was about two pages and the purpose
of this pay these two pages was to make
this critical missing essential context
clear her in her backstory yes okay
sorry I'm actually that it was her
motivation it was the Lion dialogue for
her backstory but yeah so both both what
the two things that she knew that we
didn't know her experience were remedied
with a change of dialogue and adding a
two page scene Senate or manager sent it
to actually a few of the people she sent
it to some of the people had already
seen it and he sent some new people and
everybody loved this character and said
this is this is one of my all-time
favorite characters and there's actually
multiple there were multiple bids for
that script now it's unfortunately not
usually as such that after you do script
testing you realize I change one line a
dialogue and it just add this one little
scene and the script goes from a pass to
multiple bids but that can be the case
usually there's more there's more
missing essential context so it's a
little messier than this so it's usually
multiple things they're going to have to
be addressed and that's the whole key to
script testing is to figure out where
people are not experiencing what you're
intending and why and it almost always
comes to essential context and then it's
figuring out how to rewrite the script
so here's a true story that the writers
have publicly talked about the writers
of of Game of Thrones so a lot of people
probably know this maybe some people
don't they originally shot that pilot
and then decided to redo the whole thing
because they didn't like some of the
casting and so they literally
we shot the pilot which gave the
showrunners the opportunity to screen
the original pilot for people and they
screen it for some friends and they
realized there was a missing piece of
essential context so people who watch
the original episode the original pilot
that never aired when they got to the
end they knew that the Circe of the
Queen was having an affair with Jaime
who was like her main body card there's
a there's a term for what he was like
the the head of the Queen's Guard
there's an official term and that they
were having inappropriate relations
because the Queen's married to the king
but people didn't know that that was her
brother and that whole season doesn't
necessarily work in the same way without
knowing that because that's the stakes
of the show the stakes of the show is
that Cersei will go to any lengths to
make sure that nobody knows her children
are illegitimate in that way and
illegitimate heirs to the throne so they
caught that and then of course when they
went to redo the pilot they could
rewrite and reshoot that so I this is
what I was told
only an idiot this is wasn't me talking
this was the manager talking to me only
an idiot would take a script out to the
marketplace that they haven't properly
tested to see if you have to rewrite
redesign reshoot and testing again is
making sure that is our strangers who
don't know what you're going for when
they read your script they experience a
story you experience do they experience
the characters you experience if so then
you certainly want to know what you
think you have suggestions you have
critiques you know where did it hold
your interest like you want to know all
that stuff after you know that people
are experiencing what you're
experiencing in the workshop that I
teach I just came from last night we did
an exercise where they literally wrote a
three to four page story so like a scene
but not a scene in a script like like a
short film three to four pages as an as
a exercise
and they have a main character who's
trying to achieve something and they
have reasons very motivated by that you
know stakes to achieve it and there's
another character of poses and they have
really strong reasons why they oppose
three to four pages and then everyone
tested their three to four pages to see
if everyone could fully see and
experience all the essential context and
with two exceptions everyone discovered
that there was at least one piece of
essential context that wasn't being
clear in a three to four page
the two people who nailed it are both
working writers I mean one's an
executive producer one's a staff writer
on a really successful show so they've
been trained that way so it was it is so
important to test your scripts and if
anyone wants the questions very easy go
to my website
Cory Mendel net and just sign up for the
newsletter and the autoresponder will
give you the questions so I highly
recommend after you poured heart and
soul in your script and you when you
read it you're like okay this is the
movie or this is the TV show that I want
to create this is exactly what I'm going
for
I love it now go test it and see what
other people are experiencing because
when it does go out to the marketplace I
want it to be your characters I wanted
to be your story I want it to be the
best possible version of what you're
going for so make sure by testing with
the student that you had where she wrote
this sort of semi autobiographical story
and it seemed like the sidekick
character whatever was the likeable one
and the protagonist was the one that
people were off put it by or it was too
off-putting
once she changed a few things one line
dialogue you said and a two-page scene
then people felt more empathy so in that
main character you know it'd be like so
in real life and you meet someone and
let's say that they just rub you the
wrong way and you just for whatever
reason just don't want to spend time
with them and you just don't care about
them but then you find out that they're
really struggling because they just lost
their
to cancer a really terrible cancer and
they're just having troubles in there in
that mourning period and let's just say
that you lost your father to cancer you
immediately feel different about that
sure you right and it just changes your
entire dynamic now imagine that you meet
this person you start to spend time with
them and you never know that they just
lost their father to cancer you can have
a very different experience but so in
this case it her character when you
really understood why she was struggling
why she was making some poor decisions
it changed how you felt about her it
changed how you understood it and the
end people went from thinking this is a
very very self-centered character who
just treats people poorly this is a
character who's in a really bad space
and they're doing their best and they
actually are trying to protect their
friend but they're doing it in the wrong
way but it's and it just changed how
everyone felt about that god okay it
could be that subtle
you